Nothing motivates me aside from eating
to sleeping.
I lie in my bed all day,
no one on my computer or my phone not
doing anything.
I just lie there thinking what's
happening to me.
I would say that you are.
This is not a diagnostic comment and I
don't know enough about you to provide
that sort of information,
but I would recommend that you see a
therapist and be screened for depression
because that's what it looks like to me
and I would say that if it's depression
you should do something about it because
depression is very hard on people that
produces a lot of stress hormones like
cortisol and that can hurt human man.
You know,
if it's only been a couple of days I
wouldn't worry about it,
but if it's a chronic pattern then you
should go talk to somebody.
Even your family doctor,
you know,
and there's always the possibility that
a low dose of an antidepressant might be
worth trying.
You know,
in a month if it fixed you.
But I would say don't,
don't stay in that situation now.
Go,
go find out,
do whatever you have to do to get out of
it,
and especially the fact that you're not
on your computer and you're not doing
anything,
you know,
you're,
you're ruminating,
that's just lying there thinking about
snoop's of negative emotion and you
don't have any positive emotion,
you know,
that's why you're not on your computer
or your phone.
And so one of the characteristics of
depression was supposed to have the
characteristics is a decrease in
positive motivation.
And so that means that you're not
interested in anything and an increase
in negative emotion and that can
manifest itself in.
Now I'm just lying there thinking,
you know,
so,
um,
go talk to someone,
tell someone that this is happening,
gift to your family doctor,
let them know what's happening.
Get them to give you a depression
screening and uh,
and see what you can do about it because
there are effective treatments for
depression.
And sometimes antidepressants work like
a absolute charm.